welcome back to las vegas now there are
a lot of frequently asked questions
regarding copay vaccines
uh so i spoke with a southwest medical
doctor to get more answers here's our
conversation
it's always good to see you and hear
what's going on with southwest medical i
imagine you guys are very busy right now
with the vaccinations
absolutely we are we have a couple of
vaccine
clinics going on and we've been
vaccinating the community
since early january okay and i have some
frequently asked questions
you know from the community because
there are a lot of questions on people's
mind
will i need to be vaccinated every year
so seems like a simple question but
there's not a simple answer we don't
know the answer to that yet uh
we're hoping people produce enough
antibody they won't have to be
re-vaccinated but we don't know when
time will let us know on that
okay and will i need to wear a mask and
continue physical distancing if i get
vaccinated
current recommendations are yes although
you should be
well protected from the vaccine because
we're still trying to understand the
variance and because of our concern that
even if you've been vaccinated you have
the potential to spread it to others
the current recommendations that you'll
still wear a mask and follow all of the
uh
current guidelines as far as being
careful about gathering keeping
appropriate distance excellent hand
washing
sanitizing and such are there people who
should not
get the covet 19 vaccine so uh
there's a few and right now they're
recommending 16 and above
that are getting vaccinated and 18 above
for
the other vaccine so anybody under those
ages
has not been tested and approved of uh
yet
if you're pregnant then you want to talk
to your obstetrician obviously and
weigh the pros and cons of the vaccine
and be given a vaccine during
pregnancy versus getting coveted
during pregnancy there's also a few
diseases out there that probably
should not be vaccinated so if that were
the case we'd recommend
talking to your physician if you have
any concerns to see what their
recommendations are
all right and you know this is this is a
question that i've heard from people
you know in my circle as well is you
know can i get covet 19
from the vaccine so that's a that's a
great question and it's one i hear a lot
also
and uh no you cannot
uh the moderna and pfizer have no viral
content in them at all and so you cannot
get
the covet from them you can get
uh you get a with the johnson and
johnson you get a viral fragment but
it's not something that could give you
the the infection when you do get the
vaccines
sometimes you'll get the sensation of
feeling a little bit fluish
and a little bit like you had the
illness afterwards
and that's just a sign that the vaccine
is doing its job and you're building
that immune response that you so wanted
where can people find more information
on this
so good places to find more information
to go the southern nevada health
district
website and then also cdc.gov has a lot
of information about vaccines
southwest medical has locations across
southern nevada just call 702-877-5199
or visit smalv.com we'll be right back